[Applause]
Jeremy
this is gentlemen I'll have him
introduce himself this is a gentleman
who volunteered uh two days of his time
in order to do a civic duty and was
obstructed
in a horrible way by the Crooked
Democrat machine of Philadelphia
which really has been around so long
it's a shame
I uh thank you mayor Jeremy Mercer and
I've I was at the polls or at the
pre-canvas yesterday from 7 A.M until
just after midnight back again this
morning just before 8 A.M until around 2
30 and as has been described very well
we're there supposedly observing but we
can't see we're further away than I am
from you all here
um hundreds at least 100 feet away from
open ballots that go back out of our
site we can't see them we don't know
what's happening to them
um it's just there's no way for us to
meaningfully observe the process from
where they have us
how many ballots approximately
went through that process that you had
no chance to observe
based on the counts that we've heard
it's about 125 000 maybe more well so
that should be deducted from the count
those are those are ballast of a counter
in violation of the law without an
observation and since this is a novel
procedure this mailing thing observation
is particularly important
to satisfy the possibility that you can
defraud this isn't as if you come in and
show an identification
so that's what we're going to be seeking
here and in with in Wisconsin and quite
possibly nationally if there's as much
evidence
in Arizona and Nevada and Michigan